we introduced the idea of Maximian we
said this is how you solve with calculus
but we gave the question that there were
three problems when you find a
stationary point or actually rather a
tiny point right we said there can be
three things again in the way of the
turning point actually being the max or
the min that you were looking for and
that was actually the thing I was
focusing on so do you remember what the
three things what this kind of newsboys
actually the first one right so if the
derivative that you get and the function
that comes from has some breaks in it
okay you might find a turning point but
so what the maximum might be somewhere
else can really different okay
then we said actually yeah we said yeah
and places the very last one because you
know it was at the end then we said
there were there could be other turning
points involved now we covered all these
three and we had like sort of a little
conclusion that's not at the end of a
maximum problem that we're sort of
covering all of these okay so I just
gave you the general idea and we went
through one question so let's have a
look at some concrete examples okay
that's what I'm gonna try and cover just
two today all right so if you have
enjoyed this down radio let's have a
look through it two positive inches add
up to eight okay and we're gonna get
this good number and by squaring those
two numbers and then adding up the sweat
what's the smallest possible value for M
now by the way I would assume this
question might be worth three or maybe
four marks okay as a maximum question so
even though they just say you know what
is it right they don't just want you to
say you know this is the number that's
it and well that's exactly right but
yeah it is we're looking for you to
actually show all how did you get that
right and how can you justify that that
must be the smallest possible vote all
right sir
like most problems right that this is
problem solving they don't give you an
equation you've actually got to come up
with the equation right and a platform
and there's no other actual values names
pronumerals that kind of thing we have
to make them all up okay so let's begin
by saying
let the two numbers and you give them
some names right so what should we call
them J 1 and J 2 possibly be worse that
yeah I'm gonna go in X&Y okay nice end
days anyway BX and white now before I'm
involved all right I've introduced these
printers right but what I want to pay
particular careful attention to is the
restrictions on these two numbers that
appear in the question okay now this
case they're really obvious they
actually get told you namely they're
both positive and they're integers okay
so you could say that of a couple of
ways you could say that they're greater
than zero right but since we also know
the integers you might want to use go
back to some of you near a set theory
kind of stuff and remember that this is
a way to say positive integers that said
is for integers it's not an I because I
is for imaginary numbers so said for
introduced in the plus just beads so
we've got our condition in there now we
want to get some relationships between
these two numbers okay and the rest for
the question tells us those so I've got
these two positive integers adding up to
eight right so therefore X plus y now
the last little bit of piece of
information in the question is that this
third number in right comes from
squaring and then adding them up right
so n is equal to you take squares x
squared Y squared
all right now we want the smallest
possible value before this guy okay so
you can see like this is sort of this is
what makes a problem solving right it's
kind of like well what do I do next
what's the what's the step by what
direction do I even need to go in okay
so here's my first tip right when you've
got the quantity that you want to
maximize or minimize in our case it's to
minimize so that quantity that is to be
minimized what you want to do is express
it in terms of one and only one variable
okay so that quantity must be expressed
now you could say in terms of right but
to give a bit more sort of mathematical
language we should say must be expressed
as a function one variable okay at the
moment what you've got is N is a
function of X okay so you know how you
used to see f of X right so you might
see you know these two variable
functions actually quite common we know
heaps of functions that have lots of
variables in them like say the volume of
by cylinder right the volume of a
cylinder is a function of its radius and
it's right right so two variables we've
got two variables here I've got to get
wind of rid of one of them because when
I differentiate I'm only going to
differentiate with respect to one of
them at a time okay
you actually can differentiate with
respect to one even when there's two
other variables in there but that's
something for you to do if you do
university that momentum now how can I
get it in terms of just one variable I'm
not I've got these two equations here so
I've got to use one of them in order to
get rid of one of my variables so what
do you guys suggest
okay so I'm gonna take that first
equation there right and use it to get
this substitution okay so if I take that
value there right eight minus y and I
pop it into this x squared Y that tells
me that I've got eight minus y squared
plus y spam so this is good now and it's
just a function of the one variable Y
okay so this is a good sign
lets us simplify this out a bit it a
little bit eight minus y squared should
give me okay yeah I'll get to the West
bed I'm just doing it doing the order up
there what's Y squared plus y squared
happy with that down so 2y squared 16 Y
that's all